all over the world millions of species
clash in Nature's Savage Battle of
survival on
laugh in the sea and in the
air all are locked in deadly
conflict animals fight tooth and Claw to
win food
territory and rights to the
bloodline from the deserts of Africa to
the swamps of Florida there are no rules
this is Animal Fight
Night Alaska home to the mighty brown
bear
one of the strongest and most dangerous
animals in North
America they can Tower up to 8 ft tall
on their hind
legs weighing up to 1300 lb they're one
of the largest carnivores on
Earth they need 90 lbs of food a day to
survive and if they don't get it it's
hardcore more
Carnage it's July and prime time for
feasting on calorie Rich
salmon even with plenty to go around
tempers
flare this mother bear is here to feed
with her six-month-old Cubs a risky
move any male bear anywhere near them
spells serious
danger adult males are a major killer of
bear
cubs this 5-year-old male is new to the
territory the Cubs May look cute but for
this hungry bear they're in his way and
he wants them
[Music]
gone mom's not having any of it
her only option in this fight go for him
full
thr Brown Bear's curved front claws are
up to 6 in long they're thick and sharp
like knives and can rip straight through
the Bodywork of a
car he's almost twice her size but for
her the loss of her bloodline is at
stake
and that's how you take down an opponent
twice your own
size don't give them a single second to
fight
back calling on every shred of her
strength she pushes the Big Bear
backwards there's up to 150 lb of solid
muscle concentrated in the mom's
shoulders hump and buttocks giving her
amazing strength and
speed
he lands a blow but soon backs
down this fight's not worth the
effort he'll find somewhere else to
eat he heads for the best fishing spot
in the river and starts to Chow Down on
some s
things are looking up or at least they
were the fishing rights here belong to
this six-year-old bear he's the boss
around here and as far as he's concerned
any Intruder is dead
meat
these proud heavyweight champions are
now locked in a Turf War there's no
backing out of this
contest the lowered head is a
threat a lesser bear would beat a
retreat but the Intruder is a good match
for the old
boss the boss bear flashes his
Razorsharp 2-in long canines and lunges
first adult male Bears rarely fight but
when they do the wounds are
Savage both Bears Target the loose skin
around their opponent's neck to try and
get a firm
grip Bears have huge brain cases which
provide a large surface area for muscles
to power their devastating bite they can
bite with a force strong enough to
pierce a cast iron
skillet with the Intruder down in a
submissive position the boss thinks he's
got this fight in the
bag but using every fiber of muscle the
Intruder wrestles his way back into the
fight he uses the muscles in his for
limbs they're anchored to thick bones
farther away from The pivoting Joint
compared to other animals this makes
them slower but gives them essential
leveraging
power with the force of five humans the
Intruder pumps up his for liims for a
final
effort he throws all his weight against
the
boss it's the decisive
move the boss Falls literally knocked
from his
throne it's a crushing defeat in front
of a huge
crowd the other Bears add insult to
injury forcing the old boss farther down
the
river for the Intruder it's been a good
day after
all he is the new king bear in town with
top place at the dining
table Brute Force wins big fights but
some battles need brains
too cuttlefish win the prize for one of
the most alien creatures on Animal Fight
Night masters of Illusion they have an
amazing ability to change color shape
and
texture
covered with over 20 million pigment
cells they give off a light show in
spectacular high
definition they Dazzle their prey then
suck them up with lightning
speed it's late May in the coastal
Waters of Southern Australia and that
means breeding season for the Australian
giant
cuddlefish for these crazy creatures
it's do or
die they only get one shot during their
entire lifetime to pass on their
jeans males outnumber females 10 to one
so the odds of mating are stacked
against
them adult males can be over 3 ft
long females around half the
size the males try to outdo each other
by sparking up zebra style Body
patterns this large 22 lb male is
guarding access to a rock where a lady
cuttlefish is playing hard to get he
wants her all for
himself
then a wannabe love rival gets too close
for
comfort the mantle is the cuddle fish's
power
motor he sucks water into this cavity
and then uses strong muscles to force it
through a funnel which propels him
forward like a jet
engine in a move called the shovel
he thrusts his eight arms close together
forming a pointed spear shape and then
lunges at his rival it's a clear message
to shove
off but the other gu also desperate to
get the
girl the two love Rivals lock
on as well as eight arms they use two
tentacles normally hid hidden in Pockets
behind the eyes these are also covered
in suckers used to latch on to their
prey it's a full-on wrestling match both
contenders twist in a smothering grip
the goal drag the other guy close enough
to deploy their secret lacerating
weapon a sharp and lethal beak that's
just over 2 in long hidden at the base
of their
arms they use it to attack and dismember
prey or against other Pur
suers the defender savages the love
rival
success rival ejects an Inky smoke
screen and makes a speedy
exit but the defender hasn't covered all
of his bases a smaller male pulls off a
cunning trick he might not have the
muscle
but he's still a Master of Disguise time
to get
creative he shrinks by pulling in his
longer arms and adopts a modeled color
to look like a
female it works like a
charm unnoticed he cruises right past
the Macho males to the lady hiding
underneath the
rock even though he's smaller than the
others she accepts his
advances once he's fertilized her he
drops the disguise and looks like a male
again the bigger fow may have won the
fight but the smart guy got the
girl disguise isn't usually an
option most battles are fought with
full-on face-to-face
Fury the dense Woodlands of Krueger
National Park the perfect habitat for
leopards Africa's most elusive big
cat with a lean well mused body that's
around 6 1/2 ft long and weighing up to
140 lb they may not be as big as lions
and tigers but they're one of the most
agile of all the big
cats they need to eat over 7 lbs of meat
a day but making a killing is only half
the value
this large 5-year-old leopard has just
bagged himself his first meal in over 8
days he thinks he's safe up in a tree
but he's
wrong
a lioness helps
herself and he's left with
nothing the next morning he's even more
desperate to
eat this might just be his lucky day
he's come across a half-eaten
carcass and the owners are nowhere in
sight it's a terrible
mistake in the savannah there's no such
thing as a free
lunch the battle of the big cats is
on this male leopard is taking a massive
risk desperate to eat he approaches an
abandoned carcass thinking the coast is
clear but the owners haven't finished
with it
yet a lionist batters him with a
powerful
rle 58% of a lion body is pure skeletal
muscle the largest percentage of any
mammal on earth a single blow could snap
a human
neck it looks like a knockout punch but
the leopard Dodges and rolls with
it at 300 lb the Lioness is more than
double his weight but she needs to land
a clean bite and to do that she's got to
get past his lethal claw
[Music]
CLW like all big cats leopards have five
claws on the front paws and four on the
back their claws are 2 in long and are
constantly sharpened when climbing
trees but then the Cavalry arrives three
more lionesses want to show him who's
Top Cat on the
Savannah a lioness's skull contains deep
ridges for the attachment of powerful
muscles that support her jaw and 30
teeth these muscles allow her to create
bite pressures of around 1,000 lb per
square
in theones could kill the leopard by
severing his spinal cord to survive he's
got to stay on his
back he spins around and swipes not one
not two but three of the
lionesses it's a master class in Big Cat
survival
moves but the leopard's chances are slim
he's running out of
options he can't eat and he can't risk
turning his back on the lionesses to
retreat
the lionesses launch into round
two he slashes at one with his front
claws one with his back his blows sting
buying him another minute of
life just enough time for an even more
ambitious Predator to close
in the lionesses turn their attention to
the
hyena it's the moment the leopard has
been waiting for
a lionist gives Chase but his natural
agility pays off and he vanishes into
the thick
bush he's one lucky leopard up against
four of his deadliest enemies and this
guy gets away hungry but
alive some places seem
peaceful but closer inspection Reveals
All Out
Warfare the tropical Hill forests of
Kenya in East Africa are home to the
African driver ant one of Nature's super
Predators these merciless Killers live
in massive colonies up to 22 million
strong they act as one swarming and
overpowering their
prey soldier ants are the most
aggressive and are just over an inch
long
they will even attack crabs many times
their own
size this scout party can travel up to
80 ft in an hour in search of food
devouring everything in their
path they have to feed the colony's
voracious appetite and they've just
stumbled across a potential gold
mine a towering termites
nest
these elaborate fortresses can extend up
to 15 ft
underground deep inside is a 5in queen a
bonanza meal if the ants can find a way
in a rare
opening the raid is
on immediately they give off
pheromones it's a call for the Army to
join the
battle termites will defend their home
to the death a termite Soldier raises
the Alarm by pounding his head on the
ground the whole Nest goes into
emergency
lockdown at its heart the termite
workers race desperately to build a wall
to protect their Queen without her the
whole Colony will die
out
the termite saliva contains a substance
that mixes with soil and wood and
hardens like concrete forming an
impenetrable inner
Vault up above in the tunnels locked in
jaw on jaw combat both insects use their
most lethal weapon the
mandibles the an mandibles are thick
layers of cuticle with sharp tips and
are incredibly strong whether stretched
or pinched they're made of a composite
of different fibrous proteins similar to
carbon
fiber the ant Army seems to hold the
advantage the ant's bodies are covered
all over with an armored shell called an
exoskeleton made of kiten a super strong
protein but only the termite head is
armored making its soft body extremely
vulnerable to
attack the ants Target the soft area
between the termites head and
chest in both insects the razor sharp
mandibles are operated by enormous
muscles which take up a huge proportion
of the head so there's only space for a
tiny
brain but the termites know the
Relentless killer ants have a weak
point they target the ant's neck joint
just beneath the exoskeleton and
decapitate
them and deep underground the termites
have another Advantage tunnel
Warfare ants kill their enemies by swarm
but in the narrow passageways of the
nest they struggle in one-o-one
combat it's costing the ants too many
casualties to get deep enough into the
nest to kill the termite
Queen the ant Army has to accept defeat
they'll have to find another meal that
puts up less of a
fight the triumphant termites have hung
on to their home but it was an extremely
close
call time to review their breach in
security
from one of the smallest predators to
one of the biggest with one of the
world's deadliest
bites there are over a million
alligators living wild in
Florida with their armored bodies
muscular tails and Savage Jaws they're
one fearsome
reptile fully grown males can reach over
14 ft long and weigh close to 1,000
lb unchanged for the the last 65 million
years they're one of Nature's greatest
survivors and when Gator takes on Gator
it's The Clash of the
Titans Golf and Gators don't usually go
together but sometimes Gators bring
their battles right into
town on this Florida golf course a play
player has discovered these two massive
males in the midst of an allout brawl
what the heck they're fighting over
breeding rights to the local
females it's early May and that brings
out the worst in these giant
reptiles Gators hate other Gators
stealing their
women the bigger Gators got the smaller
guy in a Savage lockdown
the Gator's bite is one of the most
powerful of any animal on
earth alligators have a bite pressure of
over 100,000 lb per square in that's the
same as the weight of a small car
pressing on the surface of a
quarter it hurts but the smaller Gator
clamps his Jaws onto his rival's
vulnerable front leg
he thrashes his tail to try to maintain
his
grip the Gator's tail is his prime motor
and makes up over a quarter of his total
body mass it's loaded with eight long
muscles around the vertebrae which gives
both flexibility and a tremendous source
of
power Gator find in short sharp
bursts and their teeth are designed more
for gripping than piercing
flesh Gators have around 80 teeth which
are Hollow and often break off during
fights underneath a new tooth weights it
will be fully functional in just a few
days Gators go through up to 3,000 teeth
in their
lifetime but the bigger Gator is having
no effect on the smaller guy armor
plated
skin so he tries another
strategy grabbing the smaller guy by the
tail to try to execute his killer move
the death
roll in the water the gator would use
leverage from his powerful tail to
launch into a spin at almost 100
revolutions per minute turning at that
speed Gators can both subdue and
dismember prey
on land it's a tough maneuver to pull
off but this fight needs a clear
winner close to one ton of angry
reptiles rise on the ground on his back
and his tail trapped the smaller Gator
is
defeated he won't be be breeding around
here anytime
soon armored skin works for some animals
others use deadly
poison life is hard under the blazing
sun of the Sonoran
Desert temperatures can reach 120° F and
there's often only 3 in of rainfall a
year
it's home to the Road Runner the
inspiration for one of the world's best
loved cartoon
characters in the real world these super
speed demons stand around 20 in tall and
weigh just 11
o they're powered by enormous leg
muscles that make up nearly a quarter of
their body weight and can easily outrun
a human
being they dine on moisturer mammals to
increase their weight water
intake but food to fuel these little
sprinters is scarce in their Dusty
desert home so when they come across
something edible they'll always try to
eat
it little snakes make a tasty
snack but big rattlesnakes are a
different
story this time taking on one of the
deadliest reptiles in the desert the Wy
little bird might have been off more
than it can
chew this six-year-old male prairie
rattlesnake is quietly enjoying the
Sonoran Desert
Sun coldblooded reptiles they're adapted
for Desert
survival they're so venomous they can
kill a horse over one 1,000 times their
own
weight he senses incoming
danger his Fork tongue captures any
chemicals given off by other
animals a Road Runner is on the
prowl she's taking a huge risk rattles
snakes like this eat road runners like
her he's 50 in Long
and is not ready to be a Road Runner's
dinner he does what all Angry Rattlers
do he issues a threat with his
tail his rattle is made of dead tissue
shaken by tiny muscles on either side of
his
tail they flex and release as many as 90
times per
second twice as fast as the wing muscles
of a
hummingbird
but the feisty lady Road Runner is not
intimidated in this battle of two desert
survivors it's a question of who will
eat
[Music]
who the Rattler can strike at a speed of
more than 8 ft per
second the Road Runner Puffs out her
feathers to confuse the accuracy of his
bite his fangs are deadly but she needs
to Target his
[Music]
head her strategy grab him by the neck
slap him hard and repeatedly on a rock
to kill him
it could go either
way these two contenders are totally
different but they're evenly
[Music]
matched neither side backs
down but then the Rattler's Fang score a
direct hit and this time she feels it
although road runners can eat venomous
snakes they're not totally immune to
their
bite with the Venom racing through her
body this will be the last time she
takes on a
rattlesnake for the snake it'll just be
a matter of minutes until he can enjoy
his
meal from a deadly venomous attack to
one of the most Fearless animals on the
entire planet
life doesn't get much tougher than in
the Kalahari
Desert here the infamous honey badger is
a crazy animal fight night Contender
that punches well above its
weight they get their name from raiding
bees nests for
honey bad boys of the animal kingdom
they're constantly ravenous and will
kill and eat just about anything they
can get their claws on
taking down a venomous snake is all in a
day's
work they can eat 10 ft of it in one
sitting with their stocky bodies and
muscular necks they stand just over 9 in
high at the
shoulders what they lack in size they
make up for impure unadulterated
aggression
this mother honey badger is out hunting
with her one-year-old
Cub she spots some blackback Jackal pups
and wants to eat
them the Jackal parents immediately go
on high
alert when it comes to protecting their
kids they'll stop at
nothing the mother Honeybadger Moves
In For The Jackal offense is the best
defense he has to keep her from his
pups jackals kill their prey using a
suffocating throat bite or simply
tearing open their abdomen with their
knif likee
canines but he can't get a firm grip on
her thick folds of Flesh
now it's her cub that's under
attack her attention is dangerously
split as Jackal number two sinks sharp
canines into Junior's
backside he instantly squats to protect
his
legs this is no place for the
uninitiated the honey badger needs to
get her son out of here before he
becomes dog
[Music]
Junior needs to go back to fight school
if he's going to help her bag Jackal
pups for
dinner if you're not strong enough to
win a fight on your own your best
defense is to pay for
protection limpets are one of the
world's great clingers on their tiny
teeth contain the strongest natural
material on
Earth they attach themselves to rocks
with a suction Force five times as
strong as a household vacuum
cleaner living on the ocean floor of the
Pacific coast the rough Keyhole Limpet
is nearly 3 in long to eat they gently
raise up and let their foot explore for
algae related to sea snails they're
happy living life in the slow lane
one of their greatest Predators is the
king of the Pacific coast the sunflower
sea
star with a total of 24 arms and
measuring 31 in across they're among the
largest of all the sea
stars and they've got a voracious
appetite to match large sunflower sea
stars can gobble up to 1 and A2 half lb
of food in a single sitting that's
around 20% of their own body
weight this rough Keyhole Limpet is
having a minor altercation with a tiny
hermit
crab then much bigger trouble
arrives the sea star quickly sprawls
over the
Limpet his legs are covered in 15,000
tiny tube feet and are equipped with
power suction
cups with all these little suckers the
sea star has four times the suction
power of the Limpet he prizes her off
the rock exposing her soft vulnerable
Underside he prepares to Devour the
Limpet she looks
delicious but the limpid has a covert
weapon to
deploy a hidden arm
that can bite and
bite that's not the Limpet but her own
personal bodyguard a banded scale worm
armed with a vicious nip in exchange for
a place to live the worm provides
defense when the limpid is under attack
his throat is equipped with powerful
muscles used to wield not one but two
sets of
Jaws he sinks them into the sea St
targeting the groove of the sea star's
tube feet right where it hurts the
most the sea star soft tissue is no
match for this painful Ambush he
Retreats and even the tiny hermit crab
gives him a little pinch for good
measure in this David and Goliath battle
the lowly Limpet and her secret weapon
have defeated a predator over a 100
times their combined
weight when it comes to pound-for-pound
bust UPS Fierce brutality is a decisive
Factor Great blackback gulls are the
largest seagulls in the world they make
themselves at home in our towns and
cities soaring on a wingspan of 67 in
they're the thugs of the
Waterfront they bully other birds into
giving up food and have even been known
to attack Eagles so when blackback gos
fight each other you've never seen
anything like
it it's early May in western Europe and
for these blackback seagulls the race is
on to establish a nests for breeding
season this adult male claims a top spot
sheltered from the
wind only 54% of their chicks make it to
adulthood so it's crucial he keeps
it but on returning he finds a squatter
challenging the rights to his
territory issuing an immediate eviction
order he Jabs at his rival's
eye
a beak on beak tug of war shows they're
an even
[Music]
match the squatter's beak is 3 in long
narrow and extremely
sharp armed with a hook at the end it
can easily tear through
flesh but for now he's using it to keep
the landlord's Beak from getting hold of
him
both these bullies use the massive power
in their wings to try and get the upper
hand the muscles that power their wings
make up around 20% of their total body
weight both gull's Bloodlines are at
[Music]
stake the squatter G decides to up the
anti
leaping up he attempts a classic move
descending in a miniature dive bomb
aiming for the eye but he
misses the homeowner lands a hard nip to
the
wing claiming Victory he chases the
squatter off his
territory he hangs on to his home and
the squatter will have to house hunt in
another
neighborhood
a sharp beak is nothing compared to 14
spikes and a ton of pummeling
force Oklahoma home to the largest land
mammal in North America the American
Bison weighing almost 2,000 lb and
standing 6 ft at the shoulder these
Behemoth battering rams are loaded with
power
from June to September They smash into
each other to establish rights to their
bloodline but now it's November and
their next big battle is a Do or Die
fight for
food bison need to eat 1.6% of their
body mass a day that's 32 lb or the
equivalent of
Pounders almost 10% of adult bison die
during the winter from lack of
food they share their home with another
of North America's great land
[Music]
beasts standing 5 ft at the shoulder and
clocking in at 900 lb the elk is another
major Contender on Animal Fight
Night like bison they fight with their
heads they can kill other elk with their
deadly
headgear when these two go head-to-head
neither wants to back
down this six-year-old bison is facing
off with a mature bull
elk they size each other up the Bison is
North America's biggest land
animal the elk is under half his weight
but he's got nerves of
Steel he brandishes his 4 and 1/2 ft
long antlers pointing 14 Jagged Spears
right in the bison's face Elks antlers
grow and shed each year they're made of
layer upon layer of cartilage which
mineralizes into bone as hard as marble
they can grow as fast as an inch per
day what elks have in Weaponry bison
more than make up for in Brute
Force
the Bison can charge with the same Force
as a Harley-Davidson motorcycle
traveling at a speed of 92 M
hour he's built to sustain massive
impacts to his head his brain is
protected by a system of bone struts
which divide the inner and outer walls
of the
skull facing close to one ton of solid
muscle
what the elk lacks in weight he's making
up for in
bravado the bison's huge hump contains
foot long bones which anchor massive
neck muscles that create a powerful
charging
Force these muscles also hold up his
enormous head which can weigh up to 75
lb
he launches his full power at the
elk but to avoid getting stabbed by the
Elk's dagger-like antlers he has to hit
the elk dead center smack between the
eyes at last the elk realizes he might
not have the muscle to tough it out with
the
Bison
he's up for still one more challenge but
one warning charge is all it takes to
make him change his
mind this time the bigger bison's Brawn
comes out on
[Music]
top